around 420 3275 to the nearest thousand
to the nearest thousand so let me
rewrite it four hundred and twenty three
thousand two hundred and seventy five
and so the thousands place is the three
right here and so if we were to round it
up if we were to round it up to the
nearest thousand we would go to 420 let
me write it so we just focus on the
three we would go up to four hundred and
twenty-four thousand if we wanted to
round up four hundred and twenty four
thousand and if we wanted to round down
if we rounded down we would go to four
hundred and twenty three thousand we
would get rid of the 275 423,000 so this
is our choice round up to four hundred
twenty four thousand or round down to
four hundred and twenty three thousand
and to figure it out we just look at the
digit one one I guess plate one place to
the right of the three so we look at the
two right there if that digit is 5 or
greater you round up so this is five so
if this is greater than or equal to five
five or greater you round up if it's
less than five if it's less than five
you round down to is definitely less
than five so we just we just round down
so it is four hundred and twenty three
thousand now just to visualize what this
means the nearest thousand if I were to
do a number line and you'll have to do
this we've gotten the answer but just to
have a little bit better visualization
of it if I were to increment by
thousands you might have four hundred
and twenty two thousand four hundred and
twenty three thousand you have four
hundred four hundred and twenty four
thousand and then maybe over here you
have four hundred and twenty five
thousand and you could keep going now
four hundred twenty three thousand two
hundred and seventy-five
four hundred twenty three thousand two
hundred seventy-five is going to be
someplace right around here and so when
we round to the nearest thousand we have
to pick
between that and that and we see it is
much closer to 423,000 then to 424,000
so we round it right there if we just
use the rules we just came up with and
we rounded down to four hundred twenty
three thousand